okay so so birth certificate gets you a
uh Social Security number so it's it's
it's interesting because you've also you
you've done a lot of different
approaches to um creating synthetic
people there's homeless people involved
so sometimes it's grounded in real
people or real
names and then you're right like some
part is fake some part is real sometimes
and sometimes it's completely all fake
right cuz now have the name I have the
social security number and what's great
is they mail you what's even better is
you get then you get to pick whatever
name you want MH you know CU when you
pick your child's name he doesn't even
have to have your last name you pick any
name so I would pick a name and i' just
say oh my wife's last name is this if it
they questioned it which they never did
but you know I've got a social security
number and then I would go apply for
credit cards and I'd get denied of
course but they would all offer me a
secured credit card so i'
I'd then fill out the secured credit
card and i' send them send the bank the
money and they would give me a secured
credit card for $500 $300 a th000
whatever it was and then once you start
making the
payments I pulled the credit and a
credit profile shows up saying that this
31y old man with a social security
number that I know was issued you know a
couple months ago has three three credit
cards they don't even say secure they
just say there's like this credit card
is500 it was issued by Bank of America
this one was issued by Capital One this
one so I've got three of them but I had
no credit
scores so at that point I kind of kicked
back and waited and I just kept making
payments and I remember thinking to
myself I'll bet you they don't that the
credit bureaus don't generate credit
scores for at least a year and I was
like God this is going to be a year-long
process and while that was happening I
started other I was starting other ones
cuz I figured at least in Year I'll have
a bunch of these secur you know these um
we call them like Phantom borrowers but
now they call them synthetic identities
so at least I would have these synthetic
identities and maybe I could do
something with them but what happened
was at six months I went and I randomly
pulled the guy's credit you know the
person's credit and
705 credit scores 705 701 695 I was like
oh my you only needed a 620 to borrow to
get a 95% % loan from the bank so I was
like oh my God this is in this is
amazing sure enough a month later the
other ones I had started all of them Bam
Bam Bam so what do you do with a phantom
borrower like what how do you make money
on this so I think most people if you
were just like a scammer a fraudster you
would you would probably just get credit
cards and maybe build up that history or
maybe try and borrow a personal loan uh
which is limited you know it's personal
loans are used to be you used to be you
could go
to uh an FDIC insured bank which borrows
money
those you know the personal loans they
lend out at the max $15,000 you know so
you could do that so you can go through
this whole process creating a fake
identity getting a card paying it off
building up credit and then you get
$155,000 at the end or right you get 15
maybe you know if you want to keep
making the payments you know if you
could wait a year you could probably get
15,000 uh maybe you could maybe get 20
30,000 and a bunch of little smaller
ones you know you get 7500 cuz I did I
did there was $7,500 from City Bank you
know $5,500 from American General so you
maybe get what 25,000 you know maybe
30,000 in personal loans maybe you can
you could you could then apply for you
maybe get another 20 or 30,000 in
regular credit cards you know 10,000
here 8,000 5,000 and then you go to the
lower department store cards and you go
to Home Depot you get 1,000 you get 500
so it ends up being maybe you can get 50
60,000 maybe if you really good you
could get up to 80 or $100,000 in credit
cards and personal loans if you really
knew what you were doing but per person
per identity per identity but I had the
ability
to to leverage that perfect those
perfect credit profiles against
properties
and I mean ultimately that's what I end
up doing and and so each one of those
identities was
worth you know a few million can you
explain how that works so uh to leverage
them against property so how does that
work with the mortgage so what I did
eventually I mean this would like is
down the road but you know I mean at
this point when things are just my whole
life had kind of gone off the The
Rails I was on federal probation and and
so what I did decided I was going to do
was start running a scam a much larger
scam and what I was going to do was it I
was going to start flipping properties
right like buy houses cheap fix them up
and sell them there's an area of Tampa
called eore
City so I was going to start flipping
houses in eor city and you know I
thought okay I can I can buy these
houses for you could buy a really crappy
house at that time for 50 $60,000 let's
say 50 and then you could put $25,000
into it in renovations you could
renovate it for 25 and maybe you could
get an appraisal for a
hundred so I thought what I could do is
I
can I can buy these houses renovate them
and sell them to you know regular
people but I also had been working on
the synthetic identities and then I
thought well or I could just sell them
to synthetic identities and then I
wouldn't have to dump 25,000 into it
right and these guys are perfect they
have perfect credit I can provide W2s
and paystubs because by this point I'm
manufacturing
businesses so I've got I've got I've
Incorporated businesses I've got
websites for the businesses W2s pay stub
so these guys have these guys look
perfect so I figured I'll buy these
properties for 50,000 sell it to these
guys for 100 maybe I'll pocket 40 or
50,000 I don't really have to do
anything but that seemed short-sighted
so I thought what would be even better
is that if I did a little bit of
Renovations and then I sold it for much
higher maybe I put 10,000 clean up the
outside of it because these guys don't
care what the inside of of the property
looks like you know they they're not
they don't exist
so and then I but I can't how am I going
to get an appraisal for
$100,000 well do you you know how
appraisals work okay so the bank sends
an appraiser out or at that time you
could provide an appraisal they can
review it so they'll do what's called a
Desktop review they review it they
review it
on um on the computer they never go out
to the property or they send someone out
they they call that you know it's like a
field review they send someone out and
they just look at the house they don't
go in it though so I have to clean out
the clean up the outside of the house so
what I did was but the problem is is if
your house is you're trying to sell that
house for let's say 200,000 the other
house they have to pick three comparable
sales in the area that are also going to
support a a
$200,000 sales price well there's no
other houses selling for $200,000 near
this house so I thought if I want to get
these things appraised for 200
250,000 I have to have comparable sales
and that appraisal is going to be
reviewed so what I did
was I started I went out and I bought
this house for
50,000
and I recorded the sale at
$200,000 So when you buy a house for
$100,000 you pay $700 in dock
stamps but if you pay the extra an extra
700 bucks the sale shows up for
$200,000 I'm buying these things for 50
so I'm paying $350 and I'm just paying
an extra
$1,00
50 so I'm so it ends up being you know
$1,400 but the but the sale shows up at
$200,000 on a house that's a a crack
house I bought for
$50,000 now I go I trim the trees we mow
the yard we clean up the porch we put a
porch rail on maybe we paint it real
nice we black out all the windows you
can't see inside um but from the from
the curb it looks great and I get an
appraisal so I do that with that house I
do that with another house all within in
a mile so I buy four houses knowing I
can use the all there's a subject and
three comparables for all of them so the
first thing I did I bought four houses
for 50,000 60,000 40,000 and I recorded
the values at you know 210 200
190 so I get an appraiser to come out
there he appraises it he said of course
he says it's horrible but there's
comparables here now of course it is in
bad shape and he says it's in bad shape
but I I go ahead and I correct all that
so I correct it so now if you if you
review the appraisal and you're in
California or even if you drive your car
down your the appraiser comes to the
house and looks at it from the street it
looks fine but the truth is I've got
$60,000 into this property and you're
appraising it for 200,000 so the bank's
rated not they're not going to lend 200
but they'll lend 1990 so the bank is
ready to
lend this synthetic borrower
$190,000 on a house that I have 60,000
in so I walk so I schedule a
closing and we close on the house and I
walk away with
$60,000 you know and and the thing is
like the problem was is by the time I
got to this point I knew so many people
in the industry I nobody had to really
at that point show up although I've had
people show up for the synthetics and
signed for them almost all the closings
nobody ever showed up I just showed up
and said to the title uh to the title
agency and said hey my borer he's at
work right now he can't make it can I
just take the file and I'll have him
sign all the documents at his work and
I'll bring him back he's like an hour
and a half away from here I'll be back
in two or three hours they're like oh
wow that man Matt thank you so much and
they would give it to me and I'd go sit
in the parking lot and I'd sign all the
documents and i' wait an hour or two and
I'd come back in and say here you go H
how are you able to keep all this in
your mind because you have to not slip
up in any of these conversations it's
pretty easy for me to for me to keep
them everything in the correct category
does that make sense like it's it's I'm
not great at a lot of things but this I
was very good at but well there's these
Phantom people that exist and they were
becoming real people in your mind is
then like you're able to tell good
stories with with those people right
like because if you're talking to the
appraiser if you're talking to the
everybody in involved well keep in mind
the appraiser almost never meets the
borrower never not even like 99.99 99%
of the time they never meet them but you
have to talk about them yeah so I guess
what I'm asking is you're able to
converse fluently about these synthetic
identities yeah they they all had
different jobs they all had they all the
jobs were basically they were all on the
job for 5 years they were all it was a
lot of it was there's a template yeah
exactly but I got it yeah listen all
matter of fact almost every one of them
had the same birth date you know so
because I you know who knows um there's
so it it yeah it wasn't difficult and
keep in mind the a lot of the the
Brokers barely ever meet um meet the bar
they call in on the phone but it didn't
matter anyway cuz I'm walking in saying
I got a slam dunk deal for you MH and
they're like oh wow Matt you got the W2s
the pay stubs you've got all the you got
all their uh their rental history you
have everything done it's perfect thank
you so much they're happy to do it hey I
print up the docs and I'll have them go
sign it great wow thank you you know
assuming they didn't already know about
it almost everybody involved in this by
the time I was done was involved there
was probably 15 or 20 people that all
knew it was going on the full of it then
you the full depth of it yes yeah at
yeah maybe not 100% everything but but
they definitely knew this is fraud and
they were still going along with it yeah
yeah keep in mind that even when I give
you an
example one of
my you know let's take this happened
with almost all of them was he would buy
five
houses so the guy B what happens the
basic design was I buy the
houses I record the values higher
and this person buys all five houses
refinances them he ends up borrowing a
little bit over a million dollars in his
name uh then of course then I go and I I
get um personal loans from several Banks
I get credit cards I run up all of his
credit cards by this point I've got 10
$20,000 worth of credit cards in the
guy's name so the guys are all worth
like a million million and change well
once I sto paying you start getting
letters from the collection companies
right from the banks you know then they
sell them off so after about three
months you're getting tons of letters
and what I would do
is I would take my borrower's name I
would go online and I would find or i'
go in the newspaper and I would
find I would find an article about let's
say like a 12C car pile up you know so
there's you know there huge accident on
I4 it's very dangerous so there's a 12C
car pile up and someone in the accident
was life flighted to Tampa General
hospital I
would cut and paste that
article and I would just insert my
borrower's name into the article saying
that you know Brandon green was life
flighted to Tampa General Hospital is
currently in critical condition I would
then print that article out on newsprint
and then make a copy of the cut it up
make copy of the newsprint Highlight his
name and I would write a letter from
Brandon green
fictional sister to the collection
companies saying several months ago my
brother was in a horrible car accident
he is currently they've got the article
they have the highlighted name he
clearly was in in this uh in this
accident he is currently in a coma and
the doctors say even if he wakes up from
the coma he will never work again that
you know so you might as well just
foreclose on stop writing L letters and
take the houses back and that's all
they're looking for is is is a reason at
this point even if they look into
Brandon green they can't figure out if
he's a real person or
not because he's got a social security
number he's got and everything went bad
at the same time he's got multiple
rental properties or his primary
residence all of his credit cards went
bad everything went bad we have an
excuse we have a letter that happens
people get divorced they lose their job
they get in accidents it's reasonable
when they look into it all looks
legitimate even if they ordered another
appraisal by this point it's not four
comparable sales or three or four
comparable sales by this point it's like
10 15 20 30 40 50 CU I kept making more
and more of these guys what was your
just a almost like a tangent what's your
thinking process there's a lot of
cleverness going on here so like uh the
the car pileup as a solution newspaper
and you mail
it what are you sitting there alone and
thinking through this like how do you
come up with that idea it's a it's a
very interesting a very clever
Innovative idea so at first I I thought
about making like a a fake death
certificate M he died you know but I
thought I don't know like what if you
know like some of these places had like
you know uh you know primary mortgage
insurance like what if the primary
mortgage insurance like what if they try
and claim cuz he was dead or like I
don't know I don't know that side so I'm
like I don't want to do that I want to
do something that's semi- verifiable and
third Pary it's like a third party
telling you this is what happened I
thought well like the newspaper you know
and you know or do I claim bankruptcy
and I've done that I've gone and got the
bankruptcy forms right you can go to the
bankruptcy court and they'll give you
forms to mail to all of your uh
creditors and you mail them they stop
contacting they wait to be no located by
or notified by the bankruptcy court but
my fear there is you know uh nobody's
ever going to notify them like I'm not
going through bankruptcy for one of
these guys so it was like this is a this
is a better bet than just writing a
letter saying I'm going through a
divorce my wife's keeping those houses
that's her problem you know you could do
there's lots of things you could do but
to me this was they're not going to try
and how do you how do you shut it down
without him dying how do you shut that
down this is how you shut it down he's
in a coma he'll never work again he was
in a car accident here's the proof he
can't even write you I'm his sister I
wrote you the letter is it's a onetime
letter that seems to um tie up
allend
exactly you know I can only know the ex
exactly how
that you know what sparked that is as
much as there were so many other avenues
that I could have gone that I was I just
didn't know I but you were thinking
through all those different Avenues are
you mostly thinking
alone I mean you know I had guys I was
bouncing ideas ideas off of there were
other guys that were involved in the
scam you know everybody I think that
scam ended up making like I think the
FBI said it was like 11.5 million or
something and and you know but but there
were so many other people that were
involved in that scam that were you know
this guy's getting 50 this guy's getting
20 you know 177,000 20,000 25,000 and
you know the we're just doing it
constantly and so the bank would
foreclose on that property they'd take
it
back they put it back on the MLS they
put it back on the MLS for 100 for2
200,000 it wouldn't sell then they drop
it to you know 150 wouldn't sell then
they drop it to 125 130 wouldn't sell
they drop it to 90 and somebody buy it
for like 90 it wasn't worth 90 but by
that point that whole area had we' done
so many houses at that point the whole
area shot up and the the FBI said uh we
did 109 houses I don't think that's true
but wow we we when I end up leaving
Tampa after that scam falls apart and
the FBI shows up
Forbes came out with an article whatever
six months later and they
said that the eore City ZIP code was one
of the top 20 fastest growing z um
appraising areas in the country and you
know everybody was like oh that's mad
cuz this place is a dump like this is is
a horrible place like this is and I
remember one time I had talked to a guy
you know years later and he was like ah
all the comparable sales have dried up
like when you left they were nothing
even close to
200,000